just like last year apple has released
four new iphone models but the lineup is
vastly different this time with apple
completely changing their strategy with
the new 14 plus model and they didn't
even raise the prices on the pros making
it even more difficult than last year to
choose the right iphone model so in this
video i'm gonna go through 14 purchasing
mistakes that you need to avoid in order
to make the right choice and then i'm
actually going to give you some real
practical advice on which one to buy
depending on what you really care about
so let's jump right into the first
mistake you need to avoid and that's
thinking you have to buy the pro models
if you want the best features and value
because the regular 14s get the same 128
gigs of storage as the pro models and
they now get six gigs of ram for keeping
your apps open just like the pros and
even though the pro models have better
camera features the regular ones now get
sensor shift stabilization with action
mode as well as finally getting
cinematic mode in 4k
just like the pro models and they also
get the same new selfie camera features
and of course people who simply wanted
the large display can now go with the
new 14 plus model instead of having to
spend eleven hundred dollars on the pro
max but for mistake number two don't
assume that the displays between these
two are basically the same because
they're far from it the pro models now
get brand new upgraded displays with up
to a massive 2000 nits of outdoor
brightness with 1600 nits peak for hdr
content compared to only 1200 on the
regular 14s and up to a thousand nits of
manual brightness compared to 800. on
top of that the pro models finally got
rid of the notch to utilize the new
dynamic island feature with the pill
shaped cutout that morphs into the
content that you're using totally
changing how the ui feels and of course
the pros get pro motion technology with
refresh rates up to 120 hertz for
buttery smooth animations as well as now
going down to one hertz for better
battery life and to enable the new
always on display which makes it feel
like a totally different phone and for
mistake number three don't assume that
the pro max model gets the best camera
features like it did in the iphone 12
lineup because now the features are
identical except for the display and
battery sizes no other differences at
all making it great for people who want
to try out the smaller size of the pro
but don't want to sacrifice features now
for number four if you're looking for
the best 5g in the connectivity features
you don't have to go all out with the
pro models because this year we didn't
get any special exclusive features on
the pros like we expected the lightning
port speed is still the same with no
upgrades and they're all still on
regular wi-fi 6 instead of wi-fi 6e and
basically everything else is the same
including the new bluetooth 5.3 upgrade
and for mistake number five if you're
someone who absolutely hates large
camera bumps that stick out front from
the phone then you need to avoid buying
the pro models because the camera bumps
are absolutely massive this year just
look at the difference in the footprint
of the square bump itself and now look
at the profile view the camera bump on
the 14 pro and pro max stick out way
more than ever before and it'll most
likely cause your iphone to wobble when
on a flat desk so avoid that mistake if
you hate large camera bumps and moving
on to number six don't assume that the
a16 chip in the pro and pro max is gonna
be a huge upgrade in performance
compared to the regular 14s because it
still has the same 6 core cpu with minor
performance improvements and on top of
that the 14s now come with the 5 core
version of the gpu from the 13 pro which
is actually really fast and on top of
that apple mentioned that the thermal
system is upgraded on the 14s which will
by itself give a huge boost in
performance compared to the previous 13
models so don't feel like you need the
a16 chat now the next mistake you need
to avoid is browsing the open web
without being protected by a vpn like
our sponsor private internet access
which basically changes your ip address
and reroutes your internet traffic
through an encrypted tunnel to hide and
protect your online activity from your
isp the network admin and the government
on all of your devices and that means
hackers can't see your keystrokes
passwords accessed files or internet
activity and the best feature is that
pia has 50 servers in 50 states as well
as many other countries so you can
access content that's not available
where you live or even watch a
television premiere before it becomes
available in your time zone private
internet access is also the most
customizable vpn on the market and the
world's most transparent vpn provider
with over 30 million downloads and they
never record or store any user data so
go ahead and click the link in the
description and pin comment below to get
up to 82 off and an extra three free
months and don't worry signing up is
risk-free with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so check out pia today moving
on to mistake number eight if you want
the absolute best camera features out
there you need to get one of the pro
models because they pack features you
simply can't get on the regular ones
first of all the pros get the new 48
megapixel camera system that supports
full resolution in pro raw mode and they
use pixel binning to combine four pixels
into one greatly improving low light
photos and night mode especially thanks
to second gen optical stabilization and
because only the pro models get the
lidar scanner they're the only ones that
can take night mode portrait photos as
well as better portraits in general not
only that but the ultrawide camera is
much improved this year and enables
macro photography which the regular 14s
don't get and don't forget that the pro
models get the additional telephoto lens
as well however mistake number nine is
assuming that the 48 megapixel sensor on
the pro models allows for 8k video
recording because apple is unfortunately
not supporting that mode at all you
still only get the same 4k but it might
actually be worse than the 4k on the
regular models because there's a chance
that the pro models will be forced to
crop in on the large 48 megapixel sensor
and only use the middle 12 megapixels
leading to smaller pixel sizes and worse
low light but we're gonna have to test
that out to be sure so subscribe right
now now on to number 10 apple mentioned
that the iphone 14 plus has the best
battery life in any iphone yet however
that's only when you're playing back
audio where it gets a hundred hours
instead of 95 on the pro max but in
reality apple rates the pro max as
getting 29 hours of video playback
compared to 26 on the plus which is much
more accurate in terms of real world
battery life so the pro max is still the
best now onto mistake number 11 just
like before apple no longer includes a
charging brick in the box so you'll have
to buy one separately but before you buy
apple's 39 30 watt charger to take
advantage of fast charging stop because
you can get an even better and more
compact 30 watt gan charger for only 22
dollars right now on amazon so check out
the link below and for mistake number 12
i fully believe that the pro models are
the ones to go with right now because
that new pill shaped cutout design is
going to be sticking around for the next
couple of years in fact ross young
believes that the regular iphone 15
models next year will also ditch the
notch and then you'll feel like you made
a huge mistake by buying the notched 14s
so keep that in mind now for number 13
if you're going to be upgrading to an
iphone 14 model this year don't make the
mistake of not buying apple care plus
because apple has secretly upgraded it
to now include unlimited repairs for
accidental damage compared to previously
where it only allowed for two incidents
of damage every year which is actually a
huge upgrade for clumsy people out there
so i definitely think it's worth it
finally for mistake number 14 if you're
upgrading from an older iphone that
doesn't support max safe you need to
keep in mind that if you're buying a
thick case you got to make sure that it
has max safe magnets built in or else
the magnetic connection won't be strong
enough to work through that case on top
of that you need to realize that only
apple's 15 watt max save charger
supports the fastest wireless charging
speeds all of the other third-party
models are limited to 7.5 watts so if
you want the fastest wireless charging
get apple's magsafe charger using the
link below and now let's finally get
into the buyer's guide portion of this
video starting off with who should be
buying the regular iphone 14 model of
course it's for those who are on a
budget looking to upgrade their iphone
for the least expensive price since it's
799 dollars or only 33 bucks a month and
because of that it's likely also a good
first iphone for android users who are
finally deciding to switch over since
many android phones start at a lower
base price and of course the 14 plus
model is meant for those who have always
wanted to try out the larger 6.7 inch
display of the pro max model but weren't
willing to dish out eleven hundred
dollars to do so so it's actually really
nice of apple to give people that less
expensive 900 option especially since
the plus gets quite a bit better battery
life compared to the regular 14 which is
another reason you might want to get
that instead now the 6.1 inch 14 pro
model is for those who want the best of
the best camera features the best
materials like the stainless steel frame
and of course those who want the
absolute best display and the brand new
pill shaped cut out with the dynamic
island feature not only that but you of
course get the buttery smooth 120 hertz
pro motion feature and the always on
display as well as many other upgrades
including the huge camera upgrades so
it's basically for those who want the
best of the best for the same 1 000
price as before and finally the 14 pro
max is for those who want the best
features with the largest display and
the best battery life basically the king
of all iphones and as a bonus the larger
display is going to make the pill-shaped
cutout look smaller as well as the
actual bezel size so it'll give you the
ultimate experience for consuming media
playing video games and anything else
you can do on your iphone so there you
guys go hopefully this video helped you
make a decision on which iphone 14 model
to buy and if you're going to be
upgrading let me know which model you're
upgrading from down in the comment
section below and definitely click the
circle about to subscribe because we're
gonna be reviewing all of these in depth
very soon so thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]